okay we'll plan the southern edge
collect a start
president is there an option menu yeah
doesn't matter doesn't matter
start 910 65 that's a good year
good yeah nothing just painting I guess
just pan 9 1068 just send my cell Jay I
guess she has another soldier man Ted 16
and we touch the moon that yeah just
playing poor just playing poor it's very
sad
1971 let's hope things get better for me
and up just another boss stop janitor
but as sad
yeah mustache though yeah
1972 year later my sauce scrubbing
toilets but to fan out
okay I hit that past part but I guess
there's that bad burn
where's this day
who is this door okay
is that not no only but not pop yeah it
does pop that's word
okay
interesting interesting okay I gotta get
a flat card somewhere that's just nuts a
see this is Joe mr. Hill wants to see
mr. Hale
my office get in there get in there
yeah take this life up that can't very
much that take - else maybe
Zach
yeah I take this robbery clap thank ya
and play the month me play fit me
and look I got the level access card now
okay let me get out of here No
perfect
it's me I work on our John I hey y'all
sweetie
mr. Hill is expecting you just walk
ready what's the matter sugar cat got
your tongue
just yeah very sassy
I'll go see my tell her mr. hell its gel
but err what its chapters Joseph about
two years sigh yes then by now Yuma
security may be just a word to most
people Jasper if we understand that it
means the safety of every citizen of
this country it also means a lot of
pressure a lot and so here we met it
don't think the company doesn't notice
it's hard
this means that from now on you will be
in charge that's right
that means downstairs lab sanitation
drain assignments I thank you I know you
made a great team but Frank own of
course you understand that we won't be
able to present you with a fancy title
or a miserable pay raise this is okay I
got an access card that the neck sent
so I guess you got to go upstairs now
back down back down just another to have
work you know just another day at work
all right
but at least I got the nice outfit let's
take out a job you know yeah yeah yeah
all right there all right yeah go to
there Open Sesame
I hate Sesame's ten fallen already
taking that job a blunt
hmm
we're done with that blood is
works great okay
Oh blood on the ground
now
this one's pay the guitar
like a piano
out
that's cool I don't know why pick it's
many other room
negative do
let's tie in here see what all this
hullabaloo is blocked that's nonsense
huh
should I worry
just keep away from liquid sir it's
again
and I can't wait to complain about this
just one like 23 floors woman alright
who's gonna get a piece of my mind
here secretary
miss Goulet heaven sugar no we keep
telling you boys to me you may look like
capable grub but no need to explain now
let's see what Gloria has breath now
runnin up what the heck
could I use this to press the button
yes I can't
the guys are slow
a little faster a little faster
yeah and see what else how Louis
okay sir mister are you all right no
don't I'm not sure yes good enough
listen I'm shots bad should I be writing
this down shots up and pay attention
your stem I know this because I'm
partially to blame things are obviously
vastly more complex than this but for
luck mister you've quiet and I'll be
damned if I will let it fail because of
a single thankfully you look FLE simple
enough to be coaxed into performing what
what is this it is a portable into them
it's a god Apple reasons you'll quickly
come to realize the device runs on solar
rechargeable batteries
despite this mr. between the blood and
all this space talk you're making me
quite dizzy I just take the damn device
and find me mister
all right for guy help oh I need help in
here
stay right there sir listen you got to
help me there's a guy in there there's a
lot of blood he needs help
I said stay but I work keep your hands
where I can almost flat against the
police or on their very sad
police always get the maxine guy I don't
want to be unreasonable here well I
wanted some simple ant